what do you think is gonna change I love
hearing your opinions on things and and
you you have a very good way of looking
at things do you think society is going
to change in a fundamental way because
of this pandemic in this quarantine yes
I do I think there have been lots of
downsides to what we've seen in humanity
this year but I also think one thing
I've enjoyed is seeing our value system
shift and we have stopped glamorizing
and glorifying things like wealth or
celebrity and all these different things
that we've entered this moment of
complete like eat the rich drag the
celebrities and like I log on Twitter
every day just to seem like who's
leaving party it is who's been canceled
today phrase Brooks I think that we've
realized that the people who are
important in this world are the ones on
thousand dollar a night balcony is
showing off their diamonds it's the
people who are the essential workers and
the health care workers so I think that
was a much needed shift because we were
out of control with the materialism etc
so I think that that is a good thing I
also think handshaking is cancelled
which I'm personally very excited about
is something that I felt was very forced
on me as a human because I have a lot of
male friends and put them in a really
got 12 friends to copy that many but I I
know a lot of men and I know that a lot
of men have their hands on their penises
whether or not they need to just
sometimes when they're on the phone
they're having a play having a fiddle
having a rearrange and then let's
shaking your hand shortly afterwards
do you have a penile imprint no no my
hands I want you my hands are up here no
URIs okay listen you're mistaken I feel
as a member of the male species sort of
we've run a few tests and yes
technically I'm male no we're not
touching our penises all the time
you can replace me with basically it's
you're saying it's why I had the
talkshow desk for so many years no not
true
there's too much shame there so I I
think you might be right about some guys
but yes that image alone makes me not
want to shake anybody's hand ever again
so itself